no matter your political views the vast
majority of americans were rocked to the
core by the assault on our nation's
capital
and many famous faces on tv have been
expressing their utter dismay
but for former first daughter jenna bush
hager it truly
hit home
what was so hard i think for so many of
us who have grieving hearts is
these images are not our america
i have had the privilege of standing on
those steps
and and several inaugurations not just
for family members
but for the first black president of the
united states of america
i kissed my grandfather goodbye and that
rotunda
i have felt the majesty of our country
in those walls
and nobody can take that from any of us
jenna was emotional and megan mccain
outraged with this message for the
rioters
you are not patriots you do not
represent america you are scum
of the earth who are using and abusing
all that i love and have grown up with
for your own sick agenda meanwhile
former first daughter chelsea clinton
also spoke out
she was exclusive on drew barrymore's
talk show today
i am just so achingly sad
that we had insurrectionists
storm our capital that's a great guest
to have today
i can only imagine how emotional she was
so i wonder like
when you as an adult are just sad and
heartbroken
and you have to figure it out for your
kid what kind of conversations did you
have with your kids
i think i feel like this cannot sustain
this is the turning point and if this is
not the example
then what is i talk to my kids
about a lot of things and they're so
aware
you have now joined a family of late
night and morning tv
and talk show host that a lot of
americans look to to give a little
comfort
i i really do believe that there are
better times ahead
weirdly the only respect that was shown
was for the velvet ropes maybe they
should put those around the whole
building and they'd stay out
so how did you do that today for your
audience i try really hard to
acknowledge reality
so instead of pushing blind optimism to
acknowledge what is happening in the
world right now and how we
find the hope as for the upcoming
inauguration
expect more checkpoints national guard
troops and
special fencing there is that
architecture in front of that
capital yesterday that was built for the
president-elect to stand on
and yesterday we saw protesters scaling
it so i think that has
raised even more concern about the
security on the ground
and who can actually provide it